who owns POI tricks are they the
intellectual property of the people who
carve them out or do they belong to the
community once they've been shared with
it should people have a say in who can
and cannot do what with the work that
they've created yeah this one's gonna
get pretty sticky Drex here from
drexfactor POI sharing with you the love
of boy spinning and flow Arts to benefit
your body and brain today I want to talk
about something kind of heady in the
flow Arts world that potentially has
some pretty troubling ramifications the
deeper we get into it but before we do
that I just want to give a quick shout
out to the Friends of the channel big
thanks to dark monk fire Mecca flow Fest
flow toys juggling calling pyro Terra
light toys spin balls and Ultra POI for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these amazing businesses and
what they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links that I've got down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to non-business friends of the
channel Johnny Howard Lane machinsky and
Becca beckonen thank you all so very
much for your support from my work and
my mission so recently I watched this
Superb video by YouTuber Adam Neely
about copyright in music and why that
system is both deeply old-fashioned as
well as hopelessly broken if you haven't
already I highly recommend checking it
out not the least of which because
you'll likely learn a lot about the
music industry by doing so and I think
that's a form of Cultural Literacy that
we should all have in this day and age
in that video Adam makes a point of
talking about how Troublesome it's
become having a system in which people
can claim ownership over specific
Melodies cadences or stylistic
flourishes that music is supposed to
involve quoting other people's work and
the more restrictive copyright gets
around music the more difficult it
becomes for it to truly work as a
collaborative creative process there are
some points he makes in that video that
I really agree with and others that I
think might be oversimplifications but
I'm neither an intellectual property
lawyer nor a professional musician so I
don't think it's super appropriate for
me to weigh in on that conversation but
it did get me thinking about an aspect
of flow Arts culture that operates in a
similar fashion wherein we quote and
build upon the work of others draw
inspiration from it and sometimes create
very popular versions of the work that
we have absorbed from others too I'm
talking of course about our tricks and
just to flag it there are several other
aspects of flow Arts culture that
already have no small amount of
intellectual property jurisprudence
around them from prop construction
trademarks unique aspects of an Act and
the like we already have our toes dipped
in the legal IP world but I want to
focus on just this one element because
Neely's video really got my gears
turning on it and if you want to see me
talk more about these other aspects of
Ip law as it pertains to the flow Arts
let me know down in the comments but
back to poy tricks generally we've sort
of framed them in the same kind of Realm
as open source collaboration when we
share New Tricks we've come up with
there's not just the assumption but also
frequently the expectation that other
people are going to learn how to do them
as well and likely come up with their
own riffs on the concept for many of the
first generation of poi entrepreneurs
the object of value is considered not
the trick itself but how to perform said
trick and or access the person
performing it you paid for instructional
dvds or in-person lessons from a person
that you respected now that model did
shift Once video sharing via social
media became widespread but we still had
established the precedent that the
tricks themselves were open and
available for sharing in a lot of
respects this was a core attribute that
helped and continues to help POI
spinning and other flow art spread as
rapidly as they have in the past decade
and a half but there have also been a
lot of people who haven't been as
comfortable with this system and that
have wanted if nothing else credit for
having been the first to find a trick or
for having taught it to the person
presenting it so this gets into some
pretty sticky territory and I can see
arguments and antecedents for both sides
now to a certain extent crediting a
person for having this role dovetails
somewhat with two other Frameworks from
other arts for one what Adam Neely was
describing in his video was essentially
footnoting the sources for one's
inspiration for a phrase or idea this
isn't so different from academic papers
citing other academic papers they're
drawing data or conclusions from another
example is the concept of lineage in
martial arts so lineage in itself has
some controversy around it that I will
absolutely not be weighing in on here
but suffice it to say it's frequently
used as a tool to trace the specific
stylistic flourishes of a given school
of martial arts over the centuries so
yes I think that if you know who created
a trick that you're using there's no
harm in crediting them if not as the
Creator then as the person that inspired
you to learn it and if you don't know
who created it you can always credit the
person from whom you learned it or first
saw it being performed now there is
another side to this argument and it's a
bit more philosophical it basically
holds that all things that can be
learned really already essentially exist
and the act of discovering them isn't so
much breathing a new thing into being
but merely uncovering that which the
universe already holds potentially
so how can someone claim ownership or
even discovery of a new thing when it
was already there all along whether you
agree with this Viewpoint or not it does
raise an important question regarding
what the core of ownership or Discovery
even is and how one claims it if I tweak
a trick I saw someone else doing just
slightly and Discover it opens up a
whole new family of tricks that person I
got it from was totally unaware of does
it originate with them
or with me here's a great example of
this more than a decade ago in a video
of Yuda performing he showed off what
was then a move that baffled many
observers in a thread analyzing the move
French flow artist Damien boy Bouvier
described the pattern as the product of
two other POI patterns that have been
cut and pasted back together he referred
to the concept as a cap or continuous
assembly pattern these are now an
integral part of the POI vocabulary but
the description of that framework
happened entirely apart from you to
himself so do caps originate with Yuda
or with Damien or with neither were they
always just in The Ether waiting for
somebody to pick them up this is part of
why even ascribing lineage can be tricky
and I've seen plenty of cases wherein
people get angry or even offended that a
person they don't know is credited for
having taught a move to someone else
when they see themselves as having been
the first to perform or capture it on
video now I will confess that I do not
have a dog in this fight
um I mean aside from just making clear
that I think the application of
intellectual property as is being
exercised in the music industry right
now to flow Arts would be catastrophic
but near as I can tell there's nobody
advocating for that point but even
asking for credit is in some respects a
form of exercising ownership over a
thing whether it comes with the ability
to restrict other people's access to it
or not now personally I believe that it
takes time energy and effort to learn a
new trick and that each of these things
is dramatically harder when you don't
have an example of the thing to work
from or break down to learn and I think
that the effort imagination and
discipline that it takes to get there is
important and should be recognized I
also think that the effort it takes to
learn something from an example or
teacher is also something that should be
recognized because it still exists no
matter how good of resources somebody
has access to but that's not a statement
about ownership it's a statement that
when we see people learning things
they're having a hard time with we
should hype them up
topic for another time but getting back
to the original thread I think that
recognizing the effort that was
necessary to bring tricks into the world
or pass on to other people is indeed
something that we should try and
incorporate into our own work if for no
other reason then we really are standing
on the shoulders of giants and the
energy that it takes to give them that
hat tip is both inconsequential next to
the amount of energy it took to do the
thing for the first time and it shows
respect by the same token there are way
too many old heads that create way too
much drama when they don't see their
name pop up as often as they would like
you know if you really need the ego
boost then do the work to stay
contemporary and relevant otherwise
you're kind of just coasting on your
older work and it's really not cool to
expect the people that are doing the
work in the present to keep you in the
conversation when you are not and
there's also a lot of cases where
tracking down the origins of specific
ideas becomes an ordeal in itself
believe me in researching many of my
videos and trying to search through old
Facebook or home of poi posts I'll go
through hours of searches and still not
be able to connect the dots at a certain
point drawing out those histories and
lineages becomes an impediment to doing
new work and it effectively does become
akin to asserting ownership over ideas
and that not only holds back new work
but also only benefits the person
demanding that this be done it's polite
to cite your influences but we should
also have Grace for when this becomes
impractical ultimately I think the
sharing of ideas is a really important
Cornerstone to who we are and what we do
as flow artists I think that it's
respectful to cite our influences and
Inspirations where relevant and also
that it's important we not lose sight of
how freely sharing ideas has helped us
grow and will hopefully continue to help
us grow in the future ultimately I don't
think that any of us own any tricks but
that the work people have put into
sharing new ones with us is still
important to recognize
I hope both stay integral aspects of
flow Arts culture long into the future
but what do you think do you think
identifying lineage should supersede the
importance of creating new work do you
think the work that goes into learning
something without any guide is really
irrelevant leave me a comment and let me
know your thoughts
[Music]
did you get anything out of this video
please make sure to leave a like comment
share and subscribe to keep the
conversation going and help my channel
grow this video would not be possible if
not for the wonderful support of all of
these amazing people right here these
are my flow patrons over on patreon and
they along with the people listed down
in the description helps make this video
and all the videos on my channel
possible thank you one and all for your
support do you like my videos do you
like my flow sessions Vlogs reviews
Combos and more I'm on a mission to try
and bring POI spinning and flow Arts to
The Wider world and help people connect
with their brains and their bodies so
help me do it head on over to
patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and sign up you can do
that at the link in the description or
the card that just popped up if you are
watching on YouTube there you can get
access to a whole host of awesome
rewards and help me along in my mission
do check that out please and thank you
if you'd like to check out some of my
other videos on Flow Arts culture I've
left a link to a playlist of videos down
in the description as well as up on
screen if you are watching on YouTube
also the YouTube algorithm thinks that
you'll like this top video based upon
your past viewing habits so maybe give
that a look too make sure to get outside
to flow today and I'll see you with a
new video on Wednesday
peace